what's up guys
before we even start this episode let me
get into a little disclaimer
this is not going to be a vlad tv
incriminating ass [ __ ] episode okay
this is my actual friend this is a
connect i used to have a long [ __ ]
time ago pre-prison
before he went to jail this is my
connect i've never once talked about him
on
any story time never brought him up on
anything because he was in [ __ ] jail
he's an actual person he's got kids
he's a legit guy now so my friend's a
[ __ ] realtor now he doesn't sell
drugs anymore so we're gonna put a mask
on him we're put covering his tattoos
because
we don't want somebody to spot him know
exactly who he is he's done a lot of we
put it this way we can't talk about
everything guys because shit's real
we can't be getting people in trouble
sent back to jail some of the people he
knows are still in jail over the things
that we
might [ __ ] up and talk about so guys
before you get your hopes up thinking
this is going to be like
yeah i shot this guy 40 times you know i
sold a million pounds like it's not
going to be like that
the things that me and him have talked
about would be a five hour podcast and i
know i'm like teasing you with it but
it's real life we can't just talk about
this [ __ ] he's got a kids he's got a
life
we have to function after this we don't
want the government looking at me
to look at him you know what i'm saying
all right guys let's get into this
episode but before we do
later on this month because we get 50
million comments about it every [ __ ]
day
yes goblin is coming he's going to do an
episode at the end of june
we're not sure but he's flying in toward
the end of june and don't worry guys
it's going to be a long one guys
thank you for listening to my little
disclaimer and yes i just thought this
was kind of tight so i put it on i
thought it'd be kind of funny
all right guys thank you so much for
listening to me rant let's start this
episode
have a dope ass day
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up everybody this is dopezyola
this is the dope as usual podcast thank
you guys for joining us for another
episode
we're here to talk about life
accomplishments drugs
problems and everything in between
before we start let me just
introduce this guys this is a completely
different type of episode
this is something that i we me and him
talked about a long time ago like
one day we'll talk about it today's the
[ __ ] day all right guys this is my
friend bob
this is interview with the drug dealer
what's up bob hey what's up thomas
how you doing man good man how are you
i'm
excited yeah we're here i'm excited to
be here finally
finally um real quick backstory for
everyone out there before we even start
bob i've never talked about never talked
about bob mainly because i didn't want
to incriminate anything
because he was going through some [ __ ]
bob's not in prison anymore bob's out
he's completely legit
let's talk here let's do it all right
man
before we even start um i mean not
before we start
first question let me let me just hop
right into that
like me i was just a broke kid so i
started selling drugs
what's the first sack you ever sold
what's the first drug you ever sold was
it weed
would be weed that's like first love you
know yeah
how old were you probably like 15 16 you
know
the age of exploring yeah high school
you know
caught on to uh smoking some weed and
loved it from there
you know next thing you know it just
spread there's a hobby friends were like
oh [ __ ]
let me smoke with you and then the next
thing you know
ball started moving
started rolling so did you start smoking
weed before i mean i knew you started
smoking weed before you started dealing
but
were you like that kid going out and
buying sacks and smoking with your
homies and then you're like let's just
buy an
ounce yeah yeah yeah this is like oh
it's still okay we're gonna get a better
deal let's just buy more
nice dude next thing you know just
buying more buying more
do you remember the first time you
bought a pack um yeah i did
actually i did it was funny because i i
bought it from a friend i didn't even
know he was doing it you know
really yeah yeah so it's like uh
friends are like hey come over to this
guy's house and uh he can help you out
and uh
you don't even know those your homies on
that oh i didn't even know my homie was
doing it so uh
it was a trip you know no [ __ ] so you're
selling out in school like in high
school like in lunch or after school
type of thing you know it was kind of
like more of
after school during school type of thing
you know just just going with the flow
you know
yeah [ __ ] yeah so what was your first
sack you sold do you remember it
uh i don't i just remember selling a
bunch of sex
you know it's just nothing really stands
out it's just
so far a long time ago you know yeah i
know i understand
um what part of the states that you grew
up in did you even grow up in california
i grew up in california
yeah yeah was socal north carolina oh
the whole time the whole time good [ __ ]
yeah
so growing up in southern california
what was
the figure in the late 90s right when
you're in high school yeah 80s 90s
good [ __ ] dude so you were there for the
swag days into the
prop 215 fire days oh nice man
i don't think we've ever talked about
this before no man it's a crazy journey
dude just to see how uh
everything evolved yeah progressed you
know of course of course being so
illegal and then controversial and now
it's just fully accepted
dudes are walking down the street
smoking blunts that's different
like the weed smoking when i was a kid
was like oh go hide what are you doing
yeah it's cool though i like the freedom
i think that's what made it kind of fun
too oh hiding it hiding it you know
to me honestly man growing up my mom
would kill me so
i always hit that [ __ ] i don't care how
i mean when i turned 18 obviously but
so you bought your first sax from a
friend that you didn't know you're
buying a pack from
right yeah all right so when did you
move up were you in high school buying
packs
uh yeah yeah yeah and i was just buying
packs
good [ __ ] so were you around do you
remember
the strange blue dot lamb's bread and
all that [ __ ] i remember lamb's bread
you know um was it pure kush
pure kush was expensive 13 like early
strands you know
yeah gdp the [ __ ] gdp in california
is like
like selling oranges like it's every
[ __ ] wear purple erko
yeah all the old-school strands yeah
um so you grew up in socal
did you i mean we've talked about a
little bit but this is for the podcast
so
yeah um were you i mean it was the late
90s
early 90s were you into the gangs at all
um
it's kind of weird to explain i'm not i
wasn't like gang banging but
those are my friends yeah you know so
you're affiliated
by association kind of yeah you know but
i mean
back then there was no internet so it's
kind of like whoever's local and around
those those were your friends you know
yeah it wasn't like oh maybe to reach
out to somebody
across across the city or across the
town and be friends with them
it wasn't like that you know no for sure
i think i think everybody starts like
that yeah
so now it's like internet like you can
be friends with anybody [ __ ] oh that's
true everybody's got something in common
yeah so when you're talking about your
friends or in gangs did you have to be
around that [ __ ] or
i mean i mean because no offense to gang
bangers but you guys do some stupid [ __ ]
sometimes all right so did you have to
get involved with this stuff because
you're their friend selling the weed
you know maybe here and there sometimes
you know but i would never get involved
it was just kind of to me it was just
kind of uh too dumb
you know i'm not saying that they're
dumb it's just
it was just nobody had anything better
to do i guess you know
or nothing to lose i guess in that sense
you know
when you don't got nothing to lose you
just don't care you just
[ __ ] it yeah for real [ __ ] that's
every ghetto in america though man yeah
that's how it is yeah there's too many
kids growing up back then it's just like
you know first generation immigrant you
got nothing to lose
did you um did your uh
what the [ __ ] was gonna say did you grow
up with money no no no no i'm a first
generation immigrant so
that's true that's true came over your
parents don't even speak english you
know
so you're coming over here you just meet
up with people well how old were you
came over
uh i think it probably was like uh three
years old oh you're [ __ ] from america
basically you know this is what you know
got you yeah so you're growing up that's
one thing i notice uh
a lot of kids running around doing [ __ ]
their parents are either working all day
or don't give a [ __ ]
yeah that's that's the give and take
until there's so many bad kids start
but obviously you're not a bad kid
you're selling drugs doesn't mean you're
bad i
let's get past that all right drug
dealers aren't all bad man just
because they sell [ __ ] drugs and make
money so you grew up in socal started
selling weed
in high school moved up uh there's a
little thing i want to talk about only
if you are comfortable with it so
personally this is a long time ago so
all you little bastards don't be trying
to [ __ ]
do the timeline this is way longer we're
not going to jail for this so
i personally when i was selling sacks
and selling pounds and merced like i
thought
well for a small town like we're moving
a lot of 10 packs every two days three
days is
good job good good [ __ ] like you're
doing all right you got you have an
apartment at least by yourself
um i've personally seen when i met you
is when i realized that
ten packs are pocket change you know
what i'm saying
yeah that's what i'm trying to get at
like
i've personally seen in my head you do
things in front of me and go
you just made a what i've never seen
that much
hundreds of thousand dollars in my life
that at once is that a bad day i've
literally seen 250k in five minutes
is that a bad day back then i mean i
don't think so i think every day like
that is a good day
i know but i'm saying i've seen you do
it in five minutes it's kind of like too
common it's just
it's just how it goes i guess so you
know yeah
so is that a good day moderate day
all right cool cool you know yeah yeah
cause
like there's a reason why i never talked
about you online is because
the people i talk about my old drug
dealers back when i was real
young i thought 10 packs was the world
yeah and then i come and go a 10 pack
yeah take it
no no give me back when you want what
the [ __ ]
you were the first person when i was a
young ass kid to no go ahead
it doesn't work didn't bring it back
what the [ __ ]
never had that exchange rate come back
before so
um the reason i bring it up because
meeting you was a whole different
[ __ ] world
truly a whole different world man it's a
i like seeing people that look normal
yeah you know what i mean like i talked
about that
man at your house once like that guy
brought the hundred pounds to your house
you would never believe in the world in
front of you in a coffee line that man's
[ __ ] trapping that hard oh yeah man
i've seen so many undercover looking ass
dudes that you would never expect
there's a lot of them out there a lot i
would never expect
ever never expect ever in life dude
so yeah i'm trying to sorry guys i'm
trying to be vague without
while trying to talk still okay so
like we said we've gotten out of the way
you're fine now you're doing your own
thing
the reason we have a mask on because he
has a life and [ __ ]
a regular job we don't want to bring
that upon you because people watch this
[ __ ] like yo you're that guy like
you used to sell what what's your you
know what i mean like it just brings
heat it brings stupid [ __ ]
hence the gloves and [ __ ] on just in
case somebody notices some [ __ ]
so so as of now we're in the early lives
of bob
going into into high school did you go
to college i did did you really i did
did you finish
yeah i did oh [ __ ] were you selling saks
still yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude dude you know how many [ __ ]
uh sororities and [ __ ] dudes
frats and [ __ ] is it's amazing college
was amazing
yeah even though you're selling packs
it's great to sell like a two thousand
dollar half pound to somebody
especially frat kids dude it's funny
it is it is college was a trip it was
fun
do you have anything from there you took
away um
and besides education i mean
no i mean every every day has been a
learning experience you know
i think you learn through trial and
error a lot of times you mess up it's
probably kind of
glad you're messed up early in life then
later on you know
that's true as long as you don't make
the same mistakes twice
that's true man yeah yeah yeah so
what's the average day you in high
school selling uh i mean the average day
of you as an adult after college
obviously when i met you you're still
selling [ __ ] pounds yeah so
once it got to the time where you're out
of college you still don't have kids yet
you're out of college you're not a
little kid anymore now you're selling
packs what's
what do you do what for people at home
what's the [ __ ] drug dealer making
money
average life like what's the average day
when you're not selling packs what are
you guys doing man
i don't know dude i mean you're always
on standby
yes that's why i hated it that's i think
that's the one downfall of
the industry that you're full-time
hustling so you're always on standby
every deal is time sensitive so if that
phone rings
and you don't want to do it guess what
it's going somewhere else
and they might not come back yeah so
it's kind of like oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna go have dinner oh [ __ ]
dinner's canceled baby let's go
yeah oh [ __ ] i'm gonna go to the bar
have a drink with some homies guess what
canceled
gotta go so i get it you know
it has ups and downs i guess yeah
that was the thing for for me it's like
i have to be home at all times
i can't be gone it was the worst that
was the
for you is different you're obviously
like well there's a hundred thousand
dollars gone like me was like i'm
selling a sip
when i was a kid like it didn't it was a
difference a different weighing of
options but
that's one thing people don't really
think about or talk about in the drug
dealing oh you might go to jail you
might get rough
you got no life [ __ ] ever you
have no life unless you
make it a point to no i have my certain
set dudes
done i'm not selling in between waiting
for calls he always calls tuesday not
it's wednesday i got a day off type of
[ __ ] yeah i think i think everybody has
their little program set up
just to make the whole program easier
you know
try to organize it so it's kind of like
a business but
in a business sense but they don't
realize it until later on they're like
[ __ ] man i applied all these business
practices to
my drug dealing thing and [ __ ] i'm
actually doing business
yeah you know so uh things that
you know you learn later on you know did
you um
well you were buying packs obviously for
somebody you're not in high school with
fields
when did you start deciding like i'm
gonna stop buying passion people and i'm
gonna grow them
oh i'll probably see like after college
yeah yeah
good [ __ ] after college you know start
experimenting and
it's gonna be greenhouse right um
indoor started indoor what after college
damn you once been
one of the first [ __ ] doing it
like that then uh i would say
i would say yeah because if it was that
long ago you're doing
hitting indoor you were probably getting
them gone for 45 i'm assuming
you know uh the first main
serious grow i did we were doing like
purple og
i think it was probably back in 98 99.
damn 2000's we've grown purple oh gee
those packs been high
5800 bucks god the purples were six
no it was 58 what dropped down to 56 52
stayed at 48 forever you know no one had
ogs back then no
no if you're oh geez or the kush you're
were the [ __ ] man oh yeah
everybody had kush well not where i'm
from oh up north it was just purples
from the bay
oh yeah uh g uh xj's
[ __ ] that i don't want to [ __ ] stop
that's just no power i mean
og's took over the market forever
forever you know until recently it kind
of died down a little bit but
now it's everybody wants ogs again
so it's a trend you know just like back
then everybody's wearing bell bottoms
and jingles
now everybody's wearing skinny jeans and
i guess and they're more expensive
right yeah dude um well i know you're
not dabbling in it anymore but
you saw the pandemic price spike yeah oh
yeah
i mean just talking to certain few
friends like how much did you sell it
for him
or you know those one won't say the
grower but fools let him go for nine
bands for the og
man nine [ __ ] racks for one pound
made me happy and hurt me at the same
time yeah i would say that's like a
boutique
up niche market you know 100 it's the
people that are buying
hash at ninety five dollars a gram all
the way up for you know what i mean like
there's just those type of people man
yeah
there truly are not there's a lot of
them in california
i think a lot of them are from out of
state you think so i think a lot of them
are out of state and then they're like
oh i can get it
it was 900 even though it was 600 and
they're making 300 back home just
off of nothing maybe i think i think so
man
i mean you know better than anybody
that's what i was thinking was happening
to the pandemic people started [ __ ]
freaking out even though there was no
money
yeah people that did have money were
just [ __ ] spending like crazy
they're selling drinks i think i think
during the potamic there's more money
on the streets than anything [ __ ]
money was just moving around i mean i've
talked to certain few people i'm like
you did what this year oh [ __ ] yeah you
just killed it it's only [ __ ] march
like everybody hit career numbers yeah
for for real no no
it's true it's very true pandemic for
the for everyone out there that doesn't
know that whole world
the drug market [ __ ] skyrocketed like
every drug you can think of got
higher priced and nobody batted an eye
at it everybody yeah give it to me
because i'm taxing the [ __ ] this guy
over here yeah it just kept going
it's like it's a cool thing it's a cool
thing if you just drug dealing that long
and it finally came back like the 2008
price came back
right remember that like you said 58s
but you're doing a 99 at 58.
back into killing it killing in a days
nice dude so um you started growing your
own [ __ ] and that's when you started
realizing like
well it's like going and buying resale
or buying retail and reselling it when
you can just go buy manufacturer costs
and resell it for retail
basically right yep so how much you
think you were growing back there how
much was it costing per pound back then
for you to grow
i mean it's 19.99 i mean i'd say
probably costs
nine hundred bucks a pound to grow it's
only for fifty eight
wanna come up yeah five pack five grand
a pack basically profit the thing is
is that you know growing weed is it's
not it's not a short term
no uh investment you know it's kind of a
more of a long-term thing
you're gonna work your ass off three
months four months straight
waiting just for that one paycheck and
i mean it's quite nice because that
paycheck's a fat paycheck so when you
get that fat paycheck
you can do something you can save the
money put it back in put it back in
do something with it invest with it
versus getting a check every week and
spending money every week you know on
daily daily living you know
and then this is like oh grower styles
like yo you gotta [ __ ]
eat a cup of noodles and eat spam and
eggs
every day just to wait for that harvest
to come you know for that big paycheck
you know so
it's a little different lifestyle it's
not always glorious no
everybody thinks it is not at all i mean
the drug dealing but not the drug
growing [ __ ]
that's a whole you you're a farmer sure
breaking backs bro you're a [ __ ]
farmer back then it's like there's no
auto feeding
there's nothing like that which one
yourself looks like you're hand feeding
you've got to lower your back this is
shocking i know people stay out there
like you have to bend over no i'm
been over 900 times 900 times squat make
sure everything's good be under there
reach back clip yeah like it's it's
farming
inside yeah it's not supposed to be done
that way that's why it's harder
you're mimicking the sun inside your
room
yeah people don't people don't realize
that you said it's not a glamorous not
as glamorous as everybody thinks it is
not all the time at least but thank god
technology has made it this far
yeah uh did you ever see the timer this
that trip feed
auto just [ __ ] look at your girl from
your phone
yep it's the coolest thing man
especially the legal market now they
have like ipad pos systems
yeah this room's dropped that
temperature three degrees in that room
let me let me turn the ac a little lower
for my app on my phone
that's cool that's [ __ ] cool right
that's cool man um
okay so we got into it a little bit
we're 20 minutes in i just want to talk
a little bit i'm gonna spark this real
fast
yeah i might as well join you do it up
all right for everyone
i didn't say it for everyone at home or
for everyone driving please be careful
please be safe don't look at your phone
just listen all right
last week we had somebody [ __ ] crash
their car while listening to our oh [ __ ]
he called me and i mean he uh dm me he's
like i just hit a pole
but the [ __ ] was funny like all right
it's a give and take
oh that's good what are we smoking up
this is gelato
mixed with some wheat i was smoking with
you
that og oh from our texas homie yeah
yeah
yeah that's the weirdo smoke with you
same [ __ ] i just mixed it nice
yeah it's cool good flavor that's good
that's a kick too
okay so
the downfalls of drug dealing do you
think it's too saturated
never never too saturated never i did
not expect to hear that for me
really i don't think it's saturated no
no i mean i
feel like there's a lot of people that
want to get in on it
i mean everybody wants to get in on it
you know of course but i think it's kind
of like
kind of like depends on what you view as
are you passionate about it you like it
because there's a lot of people that
ask me for advice and they're like yeah
bro i want to get in on the game i want
to start putting
flipping and and and selling i'm like
bro you don't
smoke weed oh that's how are you going
to even sell weed if you want smoke weed
bro
i know the scarface don't get high on
your own supply that's for cocaine
for weed if you don't smoke and you sell
we don't trust your ass
automatically don't trust you nope i
know people i'm all about the money but
it's of eight grams a week [ __ ]
you can't you can't have four [ __ ]
forty dollars
and you're selling drugs you're a
[ __ ] liar but you know i think people
see through it and they're just not
gonna support you you know
sure i think that's kind of like any
industry you know
you open a restaurant and you you don't
like food who's gonna support you bro
you know yeah i got you who's gonna come
in there and be like damn dude you're so
passionate about your
your uh your industry i'm gonna support
you ain't gonna happen with that
true you know i'm sorry
um so you think it's not too saturated i
just
the way i always do it is well
on the level you were at you weren't
selling [ __ ] five packs of people
so you always had your set people
when it comes to that it's more like
you're not trying to meet new people
yeah right you reset group and
that's all you need yeah just grow from
within you know
that way it's like no one's stepping on
no one's toes
it makes everything easier yeah um
because
for me back in merced when i was selling
weed everyone and their mom wanted to
sell weed
and when you're from a poor town it's i
got the fire
for 90 a half and they're like well i
can go get it for 40. i have like
all right you know there was a time in
my life where i was looking at like five
pounds in my
cabinet couldn't get rid of it that's
how bad the market was up there
like people are down for trash we if
it's cheaper
it's like rc cola versus pepsi like it's
the same thing
like what's your preference do you care
do you not care that's really what it is
so for you to say it's not saturated
that's wild but then like i said earlier
you're in a whole different ball game
well you were in a whole different
ballgame i should say i mean
it's just it's just it's kind of like
anything if you jump into something new
you're definitely not going to have the
network yeah and then
that's why i'm saying if you're not if
not if not love and weed
smoke it grow it and then you're trying
to jump into this
it's not gonna work you know it's just
like
it's like you're trying to be a real
estate agent you if you're not really
into it
it's true it's gonna work yeah well you
know about that yeah
yeah dude um so
there's a lot of things i wish we could
talk about but we cannot
there's a lot i wrote some [ __ ] down all
right
there's a story but we scratched it off
before we started the podcast so i'm
gonna skip over that one yeah
and then um even though it's a bomb
story i'm gonna skip over that one
and then we'll go into something else
real quick
have you sir in all your years all your
years of dealing especially in the 90s
and you started growing you had to
network a little bit yeah
right you had to meet people you didn't
know beforehand and maybe get a voucher
for somebody to come in and okay have
you ever been robbed
without saying too much i mean
i think in a sense yeah
it's happened you know it's just
something that
it's part of the part of the industry
part of the the profession you know
because there's going to be people out
there you're a target dude
and sometimes you get caught slipping
the reality check you know
so yeah in a sense
you know what's really wild i didn't
think about this podcast before
i was like how am i gonna ask bob these
questions and then not
talk about it directly because you got
to be kind of vague about all this [ __ ]
so it's kind of hard yeah at least we're
doing a good job
yeah we're doing we're doing a good job
uh kind
in a sense i've been wrong we have to be
so [ __ ] vague about this [ __ ]
um okay so
back uh back before i mean let's back up
a little bit
we're in california yeah it's 2002.
what are you selling a pack for to
somebody in la versus new york
that's right so everybody gets a
perspective yeah so everybody gets a
perspective it's kind of hard too
because if you're in cali
and you're kind of like in the scene
like in the industry
i feel like prices might be a little
different you know no they
they are i just want everybody at home
to realize the drastic
change like say uh 2002
it's 2002 somebody wants an og pack here
in l.a
they're not your friend friend so you're
going to charge them
i say like 38 38 4 000. so what happens
in the new yorker walks in
same situation it depends
i mean it depends
over uh over new york i think he'd
probably
probably get like 65 damn
two bands more a third more is what
you're saying probably like a third to a
quarter more
okay what about the uk kid walking in
your door
oh man i mean obviously uk prices are
crazy
yeah if you guys don't know that there's
american weed in the uk
but it's expensive it's like
crazy price over there right now right
now how much is a [ __ ]
a pound of the fire og in the uk
okay but if someone came over what the
market's going for and you
exactly the market i mean i think ounces
are going for like
300 bucks 700 bucks bro for the zip
i need to move to the uk i'd be a drug
dealer again
because that sounds bomb
damn really seven and uh so what's that
like almost ten
no like nine eight eight nine
over here is like three four for that
same one
yeah [ __ ] dude
okay so for everybody out there you see
the difference
yeah the farther yeah there's nobody
growing weed not like this like this
over there
i mean there has to be though right
over there yeah it's got to be a few
i think i think over there has a lot of
basements too so i'm so surprised
where you think forest pods moving
trucks built in the ground
i mean that's what i'd be doing right i
guess not everybody thinks the same
i don't know i don't know i guess so um
okay so let's circle back you said yes
in the sense you have been robbed before
is there anything you could talk about i
mean
dude you just gotta [ __ ] keep moving
don't sit there and dwell on the
situation just keep it moving that's it
that's it just to just to recover from
it you know
because you're going to take l's so
you just gotta [ __ ] keep it moving
damn that was the
don't sit there and think about this
just keep [ __ ] moving bro
[ __ ] good [ __ ] i mean luckily i've never
never been robbed before i've had a lot
of friend like you said earlier
but a lot of friends just not show back
up or who i thought were homies
not show back up maybe like not raw but
just taking l's you know what happens if
i get someone comes in there and steals
your
crop that you've been waiting for three
months what that's happening to you
oh yeah dude uh gross that happens oh i
know that happens but i know that
happened to your [ __ ]
yeah really someone walked in started tr
chopping [ __ ] down
i mean he probably did it they did it
sometime at night you know
in the indoor crazy huh
oh imagine that wake up waking up and
looking at oh well what's worse dude
imagine waking up in the morning
and then every your farm up north just
getting chopped
that's insane that's why [ __ ]
got machine guns at these girls now
dude my [ __ ] up north guy got chopped we
got chopped by the sheriffs so
oh [ __ ] really [ __ ] dicks
but then again it was an illegal time it
was an illegal time yeah we were all not
allowed to do that [ __ ] 12 plants yeah
1200 plants
that's how let me get 30 recs remember
that getting people's wrecks you could
grow more
that was some [ __ ] i had mine at my uh
dealer's house
on his wall in case the guy in case he
got ready to be like no no these are for
thomas he's a patient these are for our
like that was his thing
if you could just give me a wreck i'll
just put it on the wall you don't know
marty's from uh new york that [ __ ]
sounds stupid though
yeah it sounds but it's real it's real
it's like uh
you can grow 12. i'm growing for all
these people yep
yeah when i got here i was like okay
this is amazing we can have it but this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] stupid though that i
gotta skype into some doctor in some
half a [ __ ]
office cubicle yeah like to get you to
get your [ __ ] but
back then for everybody at prop 215 days
you only got your card so when you got
pulled over you go
here's my card sir [ __ ] you and now it's
like
remember back then in a day's wrecks
were [ __ ] expensive
200 yeah now it's like [ __ ] 14.99
online no doctor visit yeah it's looking
crazy
it's with everything with everything
comes time and like just
just fast everything's fast but yeah
marty's from new york and uh
he's moved here a few years ago so he
when he first saw the weed [ __ ]
randomly bob he filmed one of my videos
in like 2014 so one of our weed like
events he was there so that's the first
time he ever saw that [ __ ] oh that's
dope so for being from the east coast
and walking into that room like what the
[ __ ]
happened you can go to jail over this in
new york well not anymore
[ __ ] yeah but that but that year for
high times
oh that was wild huh which one huh which
one
i don't remember what year i just
remember we went like
la denver oh yeah yeah that was
14. yeah now that was when high times
was [ __ ]
it was fine yeah dude i don't think
it'll ever come back
it'll never come back the same i think
too many people got money and put it in
there and they're trying to be the
coolest brand without smiling
and being [ __ ] and that's why i
don't miss it
um okay cool cool all right all right so
we're talking a little bit i'm trying to
marty you want you got anything to chime
in with because i know i'm looking at my
notes and going i can't talk about that
about that
yeah no i thought that was good i mean i
thought that was good advice about
taking losses because it's inevitable
but when you're taking wins like that
too it's got to be easier to take a loss
it's different in that world yeah true
yet you went in differently
yeah cause we're talking about getting
my [ __ ] cd player stole last time
yeah
not a gta style weed farm far shot that
felt like a massive [ __ ] loss at the
time
yeah i think i think when you're
self-respecting when you're still broke
any losses
yeah exactly that's what i'm getting at
it's just a different level of
[ __ ] yeah who wants to go backwards you
know never
it's the worst feeling it's like missing
your exit and going there's not an exit
for four miles that's the point [ __ ]
it's like pulling that sorry card though
you take two steps back guys
you guys you guys have to take two steps
back who wants to do that
never dude um can you remember
wait that was one of the questions i had
a friend to put on the notes you ever
got in trouble when you're a kid selling
weed
yeah yeah yeah i never asked you about
this before once i did
when you're went to crazy nothing crazy
when high school huh
in high school no oh like college type
college
what happened well can you talk about it
huh
because remember nobody can see your
face man we don't have to say yeah no
we don't know i got in trouble i just i
was just driving with
a few packs and um
you know back then i was like yo you're
smoking in the car it's just like dumb
you know yeah
i don't do that i never i mean as an
adult
every day um
yo the best feeling ever you have it now
too isn't the best feeling ever like
caught behind me yeah i don't care pull
me over
we talk about this every episode i know
i just it's just
just it's a reoccurring thing it's every
day of my life i love it
especially like uh i can't even talk
about certain things damn it i gotta
leave this out
nevermind let's move on i got something
for him why don't you go ahead go ahead
go go
go because i wasn't the same so like we
talked about when thomas kind of went
into it on like a lower level he made
like it was like a definitive moment
where he's like okay i sell weed now i
just flipped my first little nickel and
now it's like
and then it was like okay it wasn't that
long so you're like okay now i'm hiding
[ __ ] in the gutters at school
and then then it was shortly thereafter
you're like moving packs and then boxes
and there's this whole evolution of it
did it go that fast for you were you as
deliberate you're like okay i do this
now like
plot it out and then you know the at
what point is it like damn i'm here
i mean it's like kind of like it's funny
it's kind of like
there's levels to it i guess you know so
you're just going through the whole
leveling up learning you know i'm
talking about
i know but there's got to be that date
because there's there's that day oh
damn well that guy's moving a lot of
weed on that train right now there's got
to be a time because i know there's a
time when i went home and went
[ __ ] i am selling a lot of weed at
school now this is i need to be careful
like there's
it was that day where you're like oh
this is not getting
real yeah like there's gotta be a scared
there's gotta be a feeling we went
hmm i got to be careful
because i know you had that yeah when
was that or even
the first time you made a [ __ ] box
and you went in your car what the [ __ ]
yeah
because there was always that time every
single person in the world has had that
moment
do you remember that moment um yeah dude
i mean
just there's a time when you know
obviously when you do like career
numbers you're always going to remember
it
right of course i forget right so
yeah i do remember a couple nights um
you could be very vague about it just go
ahead oh you could be vague about it you
don't gotta talk about where you were
or when you know every time you hit a
career at night
obviously you're gonna be celebrating
you know so i had some pretty cool
nights
lots of nights of celebrating um
damn bro i don't know kind of hard hard
to talk
around did you say most people that have
dealt with doing this
like how many people would you say ended
up being like at the end of it i still
respect these people versus how many
people
you dealt with that were like this dude
is a [ __ ] scumbag at the end of the
day
um yeah if he's a scumbag most likely
i'm not gonna try to
deal with it you know yeah or like dudes
dudes with negative energy you know like
yeah well there's a lot of those dudes
out there
yeah a lot and i never met any air house
yeah
i mean you try to keep the good vibe
around yeah it's the way to prosper
yes yes so yeah it's
for everyone out there in the car going
no no no what
it's hard to talk about certain things
and this will try to
there's celebrations and a lot of
celebration nights like
it's like trying to tell your mom where
you were when you were out doing crazy
[ __ ] all night
and you're not trying to lie i mean i
walked around i got into a car
and i got out here it's hard i
understand i understand
um so what's the advice all right ready
you're not right now as a normal person
as a legit guy with kids you're doing
your thing and it's
completely [ __ ] different
what's your advice to somebody that's in
your shoes at 22
what's the advice whether it's leave and
stop selling weed or
transition to something else what's your
advice if you could if i was your little
brother i was 22 years old doing the
exact same [ __ ] as you
what is it i mean i think you just gotta
make sure you enjoy it you know the
lifestyle you know
because if you don't enjoy it and you're
doing it it just doesn't make sense you
know
that's true you know but i mean i think
hustling is like
a [ __ ] disease though you know it's
like
i don't know i feel like i'm a risk
taker thrill seeker
rule breaker you know so to me i get i
get a kick out of that
that way i can just move on to the next
also or like yo
just keep it busy let's keep it rolling
you know yeah but i can see
if you don't really enjoy it or the
lifestyle is [ __ ] man you just kicking
kicking dirt going through a bad day
it's just just too much you know
so that was great advice i thought
you're going to say some like
education like we'll get you just you
better love that [ __ ]
oh yeah dude i mean [ __ ] school's not
for everybody [ __ ] no
okay that's a gimmick you know yeah
i mean i would want to i want a doctor
to operate on me to go to school you
know
but that's just a gimmick it's a
business dude
yeah for sure it's a business it's a
church foo
see here we go here we go damn
um of course it's a business if you have
to go hey god
here's the tray give me some money since
when
why do i have to pay for faith that's
crazy three times
three times during mass that's some [ __ ]
i've only been to church one [ __ ]
time i was in atwater
that's it i've never been i've been my
mom
is that standard i have no idea would
you grow up religious i don't know i
mean
doing math these days just like yes i
have no idea
you know so that's good parallel though
i mean
talking about that and the institution
that wraps up 18 year olds and
hundreds of thousands worth of debt yeah
true
school is [ __ ] it's cool as [ __ ] but
hey if you're in school don't feel bad
right now just finish it
unless you're playing sports for a ncaa
school that's not paying you
i know while they sell your jersey at
the concession stands and [ __ ] merch
shops
that's the trip dude it'll put you in
jail if you try to monetize your [ __ ]
that's funny so
i'm gonna get into something else just
so we break this topic up a little bit
yeah what games you stuck on right now
because i know you're a gaming ass
[ __ ] damn i'll be playing that
rise of kingdoms
game but that's probably the only game i
played this i don't think i have time to
play
so many other games you know yeah that's
true that's true but when i first
met you you were [ __ ] [ __ ] up i
missed nba 2k
this year i was like oh i'm not gonna
play it really
yo when i walked in this will always
have a new game on i always had a new
when i first watched over oh we talked
about last episode he's on that [ __ ]
heavily and um every time i see him
doing some [ __ ] it's
popular in two months like i told you
that like this is a new game it's free
it's gonna be it's gonna be the biggest
thing that's what he said it's called
fortnight
like oh wait so you just drop in and you
start shooting let's
just wait it's gonna be the most popular
game in the world it's called it [ __ ]
and it truly is um
yeah i just want to hop off that drug
topic real quick we'll hop into some
some game talk
um that's a that's it i don't play games
that's it i have a ps5 i've turned on
twice yeah we talk [ __ ] to gta every
episode
every episode bro [ __ ] gta i love it
so much
um but yeah that's it
what's up everybody thank you so much
for tuning in today this episode is
brought to you by manscaped as always
guys if you want 20
off plus free shipping go to
manscape.com yola if you don't want to
type that [ __ ] out
there's a link in our description our
video description it's always there in
every video and you've seen this on our
channel before but if you don't know
what this is
this is for not cutting your dick off
this is a male grooming tool all right
we're not talking about your eyebrows
we're talking about the hair around your
balls and dick
if you don't want to look like you're
from 1971 use something all right don't
be nasty no girl wants
no girl [ __ ] wants that so this is
100 skin safe guys
from experience you are not going to cut
yourself because we all know the fear of
being in the shower and looking down and
seeing that small drop of blood
not just girls see that [ __ ] all right
for the first time first time i ever
accidentally cut myself shaving was a
monstrosity it looked like [ __ ]
carrie i was so [ __ ] scared and i
wondered
how come nobody teaches people how to do
this [ __ ] even though my dad didn't
teach me how to shave
how come nobody teaches anybody like yo
you gotta be mad careful with your balls
so guys you will be happy to know this
is skin safe you're not going to cut
yourself
it is [ __ ] waterproof all right first
off the biggest thing is it's waterproof
you don't got to worry about it it's got
a light on it
so if you if you're still walking around
nasty as [ __ ] after having one of these
you're just a dirty [ __ ]
also guys right here this is the ultra
smooth package it comes with the roller
the shaver it has the gels inside
you can't just shave dry and if you
shave them just water that [ __ ] hurts
so once again go to manscape.com yolo or
click the link in our descriptions and
it'll take you straight there it's 20
off and free shipping in conclusion guys
thank you to the fans thank you for
actually clicking the link
we see it it's being used thank you so
much thank you for supporting
the brand that's supporting us this this
helps us sponsorship so you guys already
know they get down on the podcast so
thank you guys so much back to the
episode
all right guys we're back we took a
little break we had to reassess how we
can talk i know a lot of you like well
you're not really talking about a lot
that's because there's this is real life
you can't talk about everything not
everything can be
spoken about so we reassessed we got a
couple topics we're okay we're allowed
to talk about
now let's get back into this so
um first one first round let's talk
about it
first buys what's the first buys that
you can remember when you first got
those because
i think everybody remembers first time
buying their first rolly
yeah i guess a lot of people do that
what was it
um i had a stainless steel basic
basically still they
white dial you know jubilee bracelet
just
simple because i've seen you're not as
simple after that because when i met you
when i met you
there was somebody there selling you a
watch i think i'm gonna buy it how much
is it
i was like what is that like 30 bands
and the guy looked offended remember
that he goes
it's a hundred and eighty thousand
dollar watch man it's the presidential
blah blah blah i was like what the [ __ ]
you're spending that much and
i looked you go i like it though oh [ __ ]
dude jesus christ so that wasn't playing
yeah that wasn't the plain stainless
steel [ __ ] rolex
kind of like uh became like a
[ __ ] and that's just like a hobby you
know watches
ended up collecting them and then just
kept on getting more and more just try
to add to the collection you know
that what what was the most expensive
watch you ever bought back then
um probably uh ap
what's that uh 200 000 damn
you know [ __ ] off for the watch a couple
other watches but
you know it's just at the time it's just
like a like a trophy i guess you know
yeah like you said you got to enjoy it
if you don't enjoy it what's the point
yeah
i completely understand that that's cool
though so you started getting into
watches yeah
anything else i don't know man i just
started buying stuff that you
wanted when you're a little kid you know
exactly right
exactly why not yeah ended up getting uh
nxx
oh the car yeah i remember that thing i
remember that like childhood dreams of
[ __ ] never having to
nxx right remember that i remember the
amg that was you're the first person i
ever saw with that one
that was nice oh that was a nice car
yeah dude there's
there's things you buy the first thing i
ever bought when i started making money
i just
i think i just went to santa cruz and
just got [ __ ] faced and didn't worry
about
how much money had my pocket i never
really bought stuff such a nice feeling
right
[ __ ] the best best when you grow up
shitty poor like it's not
it's crazy going no i have it no let's
go whoa
but the funny thing is i feel like
anybody can do it though
100 if you really put your efforts in
you know i think anybody can do it
yeah we're not encouraging drug dealing
no we're encouraging making money in
business yeah whatever you like
you know basically because dude hustling
is not about drug dealing how's it get
you apply that to any industry 100 right
clothes hustle and houses yep same [ __ ]
same feeling you know yeah like i when i
stopped shirts clothing
same thing same [ __ ] same [ __ ] yeah dude
we talked about this actually last time
like how is it how does a drug dealing
apply to the
me doing all the clothes somebody asked
it's the same
[ __ ] thing the same thing but better
because i can go to the bank and get a
bank account
yup that's the best feeling dude the
worst drug dealing downfall no matter
what you guys think is you can't buy
property yeah you can't buy cool stuff
like things that last you cannot buy
you just gotta work towards it you know
i mean i know there's ways around it
like the fake [ __ ] i get that the
stubs and all that stuff but legally
without having to worry about oh there's
a copper mouse [ __ ] cause you know this
house is illegal
like that's a horrible feeling to
[ __ ] have i hated that [ __ ]
it's the worst so first buys the watch
watches cars you know
just things you love that you can get
you know yeah
for stories you know like just
[ __ ] started buying well well you
started making money in high school
what were you spending in highs because
if you're a high school kid you know
what buy buying food for everybody
random [ __ ] yeah that was like life was
simple it was you wasn't into
any of this other stuff 200 another
[ __ ] watch yeah
so it was like life was simple back then
so money money went far away you know
yeah but back then it's like you're in
you're in high school in and i was like
[ __ ]
that was like the dream lunch the dream
meal yeah if you can afford that [ __ ]
that's just tired as [ __ ]
i remember all that oh i got a question
is the average person aware like how you
were saying how like when you're trying
to like wash your money these like giant
expensive rigs that are like art pieces
and [ __ ]
do people know about that because i
didn't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
um i don't know
yes there's for marty said everybody
asks marty's question we were talking
about this a while back like how
i think a lot of people invested into
glass back then it's because it's
look say i'm a hashmaker and i make five
pounds of shatter in 2005 right or 2008
and i can sell all those pounds for
let's just say 6 000 all right cool 30
000.
cool i just made 30 000 every two days
every three days so in a week you have
200 000 what do you do
go buy uh glass rigs that's a hundred
thousand dollars and then when you sell
it you're now an art dealer
legally yeah that's it that's all i
[ __ ] took and like oh well how'd you
get the money to get it
it was a gift actually from the artist
like
there's there's so many ways around it
now you're legal yeah that's
that i didn't understand cause i'm like
i would instantly break this thing
you're telling me it's like 60 grand
this [ __ ] bomb
oh dude like without saying is our
friend yeah
we know who i'm talking about bought a
60 000 rig remember when he bought that
[ __ ] rig i thought he was the dumbest
[ __ ] on the planet and then i
realized what was what he was doing
i mean everybody had a high one dude
yeah but damn a 60k
rig i remember when he bought that like
you did
what the [ __ ] is that
i know they know we're talking about
here [ __ ] this
too class was crazy back then yeah dude
i mean hundred thousand dollars
like yeah a little arp is it's art now
he's in a cage and if there's an
earthquake
there's a there's an art show glass our
show that's only one piece
now you're fighting other buyers just to
buy it
yes it's real it's real but then that's
how you wash that money
you you just did it right then and there
and you got to remember
people in the lifestyle that were
accustomed to when we're younger is
spending a hundred thousand dollars a
year on random things is
okay maybe i should try to like you know
tighten it up stop spending so much it's
not like oh my god i'm gonna die
because you made so much money more
money than that it's a whole different
thing like it was 150
on this dinner all right
like that's the light i said the
mentality is never like what if i can't
get it
you're gonna get it again don't [ __ ]
worry unless you go to jail but then it
doesn't matter
because then you're in jail [ __ ] it
it's a it's a shitty way of looking at
it but it's true it's completely true
man
so first buys buying everything so in
high school you
in and out is not a problem yeah that
was the goal though no problem no more
yeah
i mean if i guess i guess you go through
it you know now it's like yo you don't
want to buy
jordans no more mm-hmm you want to buy
art pieces no more you
try to move on and buy something else
you know yeah maybe buy more houses
more investment stuff with those [ __ ]
uh bitcoins and uh
you're up on everything before i know
about it
so you were on to all the [ __ ]
a year ago yeah you're on all the stuff
that's hyped now you told me a year ago
yeah it's crazy huh is it working save
crypto
crypto took a dump i think it's been uh
progressing
a lot lately but you know if you bought
early enough
you already made your business because
tesla said we don't accept crypto
anymore is that
crazy aside from that who knows i mean
i think every time everything hits a
career high it's gonna take a little dip
you know
he's gonna go back up uh eventually i
think so hold on
are you selling all your crypto ah all
right then we're fine we're going back
up
i'm just gonna lead the way for whatever
you do whatever he does just sell and
buy based on what bob does
i feel like right now it's a good time
to buy yeah yeah true
i feel like i should be buying it but
don't i really know why i don't have a
grasp
on it my brain is not there we've had
people break it down to us but we're
still like
yeah dude that's how i felt too i just
look like i'm just gonna
hop in but you're on all that [ __ ]
you're good with that kind of stuff
you're dealing with all that kind of
stuff
experiment yeah you know invest it
figuring it out you know because there's
different brands of it there's different
variations
of it yeah like there's even like a
podcast company that says like you can
be
on our platform and we'll pay you we're
in like
equity style bitcoin but it's our
it's our variation of bitcoin but we're
offering it as a variation of stock in
our company for our early creators
yeah it's going like that now [ __ ] i
don't know
i have no idea yeah do people sell and
trade drugs for bitcoin
oh man i've took a bitcoin for uh for
deals before
really yeah that's how you sell drugs on
the black or the dark
dark web right you're right oh yeah like
silk road back then
that's that's essentially bitcoin crypto
right yeah this is all my wallet
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] that those are the easiest ways to
[ __ ] uh
move money around you know yeah it's
instant yeah you have to ship
money oh man god i wish we could
imagine how many how many dudes got
[ __ ]
their bitcoins dude students walking
around in gap
close are the ones with 100 pack in the
trunk
that's the craziest thing would you say
most people
at that highest level when you're up
there you're at the top of the supply
chain
are most people just unassuming gus
frank type dudes or
are they mostly like hardcore gangsters
you can tell you don't want to [ __ ] with
man i think it's just who who you want
to deal with i think the market's so
crazy
everybody's in it you know it's not like
it's just certain type of dudes that
just feel like yeah no everybody's
involved in this thing you know so now
it's like everybody has
there's so many that's why there's so
many brands i feel like yeah right
everybody has their own little marketing
niche you know true like everybody wants
to get the viola this because it's more
expensive this yeah
or get the trapped out [ __ ] that has no
marketing or no packaging on it
yeah you're right it's different it's
just their own little [ __ ] hitch i
guess
yeah because i've i mean everybody i've
ever met is super nice because i keep it
that way
i don't like to [ __ ] with people that
are like oh well let me pat you down
before you come in
[ __ ] you i'm leaving bro there's other
weed
no thank you i think that's that's the
cool thing about it is like
if you don't know a people's person i
kind of think it does affect your
you know performance in the sales spot
you know
and like when you were selling a lot
back then you didn't have to worry about
anything
you have to worry about [ __ ] because
everybody knows like no bob's
he's on point why would i ever have to
worry you don't you're not gonna get
robbed when you walk out you're not
gonna get robbed inside
you're fine street cred goes a long way
i guess exactly
but clean street cred is the best now
like
i've seen somebody like no he's done
work for [ __ ] 40 years
never got you that's the kind of [ __ ]
you want at least me
that's real respect though when people
look at your like oh no he does this
yes not just i'm scared of him i don't
want to fall different that's
going to go in the [ __ ] prison yeah
yeah i don't think it's like that no
more these days not as much
you know it's kind of more of like a
business approach it's true it truly is
i like it right oh yeah you're you're a
client you're gonna have to
you know cater to your client i guess
you don't want to lose somebody but hey
don't put the guns away you won't scare
this fool he's
a square but he's got money you want to
appeal to everybody so i think everybody
likes a nice person or an easy to deal
with person that's on time
that's always accurate who doesn't want
that [ __ ] especially at the highest
level
some of my best homies would sell me
drugs were the laziest [ __ ] on
the planet
just have a gun laying out right let's
just have one just laid out in the
corner
hey man i thought we couldn't talk about
that kind of stuff there's like 90
stories i want to bring up right now
it's a long time ago okay so it's fine
it's
fine you guys were doing this show when
you're like seven eight years old
yes watching sandlot and selling packs
yeah
oh yeah having a gun up the best part is
that's the best thing like hey walk in
brand new guy
check out those packs and there's just a
giant gun in the middle but don't
mention it
and go oh [ __ ] this guy has a machine
gun um
yeah if i was thinking about robbing him
i'm not gonna rob him anymore that's the
best thing that's the best that's a nice
guy
way of saying i will shoot you in the
chest
it works it definitely [ __ ] works
effective it's very effective
um so i'm gonna get into one little
segment all right
this is a rapid fire it's called who
were you
who were you in the 90s okay i'm going
to ask you you pick one or the other
all right all right in the 90s who are
you vh1 mtv
mtv yeah adam sandler jim carrey jim k
oh i love him too but what made you get
that choice what what movie was it
over the adam sandler that made you go
you know what jim carrey
uh you played the [ __ ] uh
victoria what was it hey
you're right it was a good [ __ ] that was
so good [ __ ] that was good dude
i wasn't a fan of like the mask it was
kind of weird you know i was a kid
though so i love them
okay when it came out i thought like so
i can put on a mask
we're just talking about cameron diaz
how much difference does cameron do
you feel off the radar huh who jim
carrey yeah no
no he's still doing yeah he has a new
show called kidding it's not comedy it's
like a [ __ ] dramatic ass show
he basically plays mr rogers and the
[ __ ] that would happen in his real life
it's [ __ ] good
well he's always doing something jim
carrey's wild check it out
um tupac biggie smalls two o'clock
all right step by step for family
matters
step by step really uh still my step was
cool
yeah all right all right if you went
first off then that's your choice
pulp fiction forrest gump pulp fixes
he's never seen a movie oh i'm just
kidding he watches every day
that's the only thing i reference it
pennywise or chucky chucky
okay mario or donkey kong mario yeah
that's why we're friends full house are
saved by the bell
i like both of those that's true but if
you had to pick
say by the way me too have to is that
teenager references
yeah exactly um well then again
full house is pretty realistic there's
19 families living in one san francisco
house to pay the rent
that's a pretty realistic it's expensive
danny taylor was [ __ ] polling nobody
was paying rent there
he was balling but he ain't balling that
hard to get that house and frisco was
probably three four million dollars now
just because wake up san francisco was
doing we had that [ __ ] back in the early
90s though yeah that's true
you're right you're right all right
you're right mcdonald's of burger king
mcdonald's all right michael jackson
michael jordan
jordan i do like michael jackson too
same but this is the 90s you have to
pick based on
and then hey training day wasn't in the
90s
training day i was in the 2000s just
because your favorite movie you can't be
sneaking it in there listen i had to
make it was independence
listen it's a 90s movie i'm gonna have
to look that up but
training date or independence day
trading day
good oh
sunny d or nesquik sunny d
that's right diabetes i love that [ __ ]
um
sunny diabetes sunny diabetes um yeah
that's
who were you in the 90s and that's just
a little quick thing to get a
for everyone at home to get a feel of
the guests like all right i'll [ __ ] with
you
couldn't answer the 90s yeah the 90s
were fun for me i just drank soda and
watched this all of this is all i did in
the 90s
never sold a sack it's loosely they're
just the basis of this podcast
i know right references back to [ __ ]
full house all right
um so next question
when you were dealing a lot and you were
obvious that's your [ __ ] lifestyle
you said you're on call did everyone
know in your circle of family
did they know that this is what you were
doing or are you playing it off you're
doing some other [ __ ]
you know i was i'm just playing it
offline do some other [ __ ] yeah
you know i just don't want to like have
that judgmental kind of uh
thing towards me you know your parents
didn't even know even in high school
parents know okay like in-laws you know
oh in-laws gotcha i mean or like outside
family
you know that don't know [ __ ] like your
uncle comes over like oh [ __ ]
right mm-hmm damn don't drop in they
don't say nothing
do a little drive-by oh like oh [ __ ]
what's happened to me many times i could
just pretend i wasn't home
was your house the spot though like our
one of our guests fabian alimer like he
grew up his house he was born
into it being the spot huh um
i don't know this is it it was kind of
the spot but kind of like you know
private you know private spot you know
so it's just not like a lot wasn't out
of left field when you came home when
you started getting into the show yeah
okay okay well when you had your house
you're saying in-laws
obviously you're keeping that away from
them you're married to their damn
daughter they don't
i sell mass amounts of [ __ ] weight
every day yeah no
i get that i get that i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring up this one story
it's a lot remember this is a very long
time ago so let's
before you even like this one time i was
at the house at bob's house
and we're just sitting there i know you
remember we're just standing there we're
smoking weed
oh no we're taking dabs and you're
playing games
and there's 150 pounds in eyesight in
the living room like i can see the stack
stack stack black bags i'm just i'm
looking at like damn
all right cool what do you got and
remember guys it's a long [ __ ] time
go still selling weed
and you go oh [ __ ] you got a tax go my
in-laws are coming
[ __ ] and then you go hold on one second
he started guys everybody everybody he
started grabbing these like santa claus
and he was running to his back room
putting all these pounds in bags
after he cleans up the whole [ __ ]
living room for
like i'm saying over 100 pounds spread
out in a bunch of different strain and
but like separated and he goes
like what i said like when cats run into
a room like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that's how he
looked he's looking around he goes
all right i think i think i'm good and i
go
bob what about those 30 [ __ ] pounds
on your pool table he completely didn't
look
because he's looking on the ground for
packs there was a mountain
on top of his pool table not in back
just exposed
in turkey bags and he goes oh focusing
and start cleaning it up and i'm like
look at him go
he just made this house look presentable
in [ __ ] four and a half minutes
because right before that there was
hundreds of pounds everywhere
it does hold on you can have hundreds of
pounds of wheat hundreds of pounds of
weed in a room and not have it just reek
like weed yeah okay yeah i know that's
probably a dumb question
no it's turkey bags and yeah plastic
bags i mean it'll smell
but it's not gonna be like smell like
hundreds of pounds no no no no
one pound of weed smells like the whole
room so 100 pounds is not going to be
much difference
to me maybe i have a bad nose but i
don't all right
um but yeah that story i brought that up
because that was [ __ ] hilarious and
that's one thing i could talk about
maybe one day maybe yeah scrambling dude
it was
[ __ ] funny pause started [ __ ]
going crazy
there's a rig right in the [ __ ]
middle still
yeah they don't know they don't know
that yet so oh
got you uh are they four and two
yeah the uh they don't know what the
[ __ ] rig cause i don't know
what's a bong or rig yet you know i
don't think so i hope not right
[ __ ] they saw it 40 times yeah they
probably say that i should know movies
these days
yeah for sure but that's one little
story i can talk about that
won't incriminate the [ __ ] at everybody
cause like i said before we take a
little break and
really assess what the [ __ ] we're
allowed to talk about so
that was [ __ ] hilarious just real
quick that was awesome that was a funny
ass day
so to conclude i'm not not saying in
conclusion how about this
when do you when did you know besides
going to [ __ ] jail when did you know
it was time
like this is over let's break away let's
apply myself somewhere else
because i am not going to just keep
going back to [ __ ] jail
i mean i think right now is great
because there's so many different
side houses you can do i i feel like
yeah just gotta
what's your hobbies you know your other
hobbies do anything right now to make
money do you do anything you want
of course it feels like right yeah yeah
but what
like for people out there you telling
them when do you think it's a good time
to
be done not maybe not you personally
because obviously you were like i'm done
with being in this box i'm [ __ ] out
of here
so when did when do you think is the
time
yeah i guess when you think you feel
like you have enough to
try to do something else you know i
guess just
i'd say just do something else while
you're doing it as a side gig
until you find something to fall on you
know i guess in a point
ultimately you got to be ready to
sacrifice though like yeah he talks
about it all the time
i think i think you got to generate that
passive income first yeah passive income
going then you can experiment into any
other thing you want to do you know
okay i guess i mean it's going to be
it's a definite lifestyle change
i'll tell you that from from 20 years
ago until now it's just like damn it's a
total life change
[ __ ] i can only imagine bro just do
whatever the [ __ ] you want at home and
then now it's like yeah
i got kids my job i got to be real now
you know it's a lot harder to sell it's
a lot harder to take care of your kids
and go to work and take care of
everybody
than it is to sell a hundred pounds
definitely that's just like a full-time
job
[ __ ] yeah full-time job i don't even
have kids
he's got three kids so he knows all
about this [ __ ] it's a job that starts
when you get home from the job
yeah it's never ending that was a great
way to put that
i [ __ ] with that oh my god
so what you doing after this get
back to work [ __ ] so
yeah i think i think we we dove into a
lot we dove into a lot of topics i think
people wouldn't know unless they
actually talk to somebody and
if you're talking to somebody they're
like yeah i'm a drug dealer and this
no drug dealer ever says that [ __ ] yeah
i don't think no drug dealer wants to be
a drug dealer
forever nope i mean it's kind of boring
sometimes yeah you know i just do new
things
you know travel you've been traveling so
like you can actually do stuff with your
life now it's a whole
it's a it's a different change-up man
it's a it's a completely different
feeling and vibe yeah it's nice to sleep
at night
yeah not after dude leaving my phone on
silent was the death of me i remember
that
your phone's on silent what if you lost
like 500 [ __ ] calls
that was the you're stuck and attached
to that phone for for life
hey man but phones is a better uh move
than uh the beeper right remember the
pager
i never had a pager my dad did i always
used to use it
that's a whole different story selling
drugs with a beeper you're a [ __ ] man
you're the man
you're committed those were the days
that dollop aol internet
now it's just [ __ ] all all checked
out it's so easy now that's cool though
huh that's cool
um so yeah man without
talking about too many incriminating
things leave that for vlad tv
all right and all those dudes that
wanted to talk about crazy drug
[ __ ] charges and wild [ __ ] yeah they
can go to jail not over here all right
we're uh we're trying to stay safe as
you can see by the mask and gloves and
sweater
and everything um we're trying to be
safe bob thank you
thank you for coming thank you for
actually talking on camera oh yeah man
dude thanks for having me dude i had a
blast thank you for coming though
i know i know when we took a break he's
like [ __ ] hot
that mixture got me too that's a lot of
og [ __ ] me up
guys this is a been interview with bob
interview the drug dealer like interview
with a vampire i just thought it was the
best this is the best title
the best time martial about that earlier
what about you you have anything you
would like to ask
i think i kind of got my questions off
right yeah i think so all my questions
would be
probably too much i i i don't have the
understanding that you have that
circle lofting questions that would
probably i know it's hard it's hard to
talk about the [ __ ] when people are
still alive in those situations
that's why i can't do it i talk about
everything so i've never brought you up
i can't talk about that stuff now that
you okay like yeah come on
now i can start asking certain things
it's hard yeah it's hard that's hard man
i know i can see it on your face like
all right i i i have like [ __ ] okay
let me beat around that bush let's not
antagonize anybody
because it's a real world um all right
cool [ __ ] yeah
all right this this is one of uh one of
many
different topics i think we're gonna be
getting into i like this as a guest is
[ __ ] different you know what i'm
saying like from our comedians or this
or that it's
a legit person that like we can almost
not talk
if we could talk about this and all the
cameras are off this would be a 19 hour
podcast
with the craziest [ __ ] things in the
world we talk about yeah
if this to your living room this is a
whole different story you have to go
full
vocal transformer and uh yes
switch up the lighting and shift
everything you have to be in the [ __ ]
complete dark
completely changed voice every single
thing if you want to talk about certain
things a hundred percent
i'd be sick
let's leave it at that this is the
dabble into the drug world
guys thank you so much for watching bob
thank you for being here um let's
i think we're gonna go get [ __ ] up or
something we're gonna do something um
thank you guys so much for watching
this has been an interview with the drug
dealer this has been the dope as usual
podcast
if you're driving please be safe don't
be like
anybody that we talked about last
weekend crashing their [ __ ] car while
laughing he said
so i mean maybe we're so funny crashed
or you're negligent but just be safe
guys please be careful if you're driving
if you're at home smoke with your homies
if you're at home smoking by yourself
just listening at work
thank you for being here this is the
dope as usual podcast i'm dope aziola
have a dope as day all right don't take
your mask off yet
let's get off camera first before you
take that off
all right
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]
perfect